hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel what today I'm basically making
this video in pot to answer a really
simple question that people keep asking
me but also I wanted to make it because
that question I think leads to an
interesting discussion that I think not
that many people know too much about so
I thought that I would just teach you
some stuff
so the question jumping right to it is
why I am refusing to give any opinion or
talk about debt stranding people keep
asking if I like the game people are
asking me if I will review the game
people are asking me to tell them if
they should buy the game and I have
chosen to not talk about it in any
capacity or whatsoever
I'm not even saying if I like it or not
and maybe me putting a hard no on giving
opinions I'm just ranting oh it lost
forever but it's the the thing that I
think I need to do right now and that is
because of ethics in video game
journalism so basically I did already
make a youtube video about it I have
posted about it on all of my social
media but basically I did a paid
partnership with Playstation where they
paid me to promote it something related
to death stranding they sent me and
three other influences these padlock
cases we had to publicly figure out how
to unlock those cases it was a super fun
campaign and then inside of the case was
a bunch of very expensive stuff a
playstation pro this necklace I found
out is worth like I think like $400 some
awesome headphones just very impressive
stuff so to the section of people who
are politely being like I'd love to hear
opinion are you going to review it I'm
not going to do that because I think it
would be unethical to review a product
when a company has both given me items
of value and paid me to promote said
product I actually don't think that I
would have any issue giving my opinion
on the game ethically and completely
removing the situation I as a human do
not think I would have biased so I can
easily talk to my friends about dis
training and don't feel like I need to
give them a disclosure but because of
the way this situation works because of
effects that I may not be aware of and
also just because of how it looks and
feels to the public I don't think it's
right for me to use my platform to talk
about my opinion on the game when I have
had a hand in marketing that game as
paid for by PlayStation it would be a
really gross thing to do this is a
personal choice but I do also want to
note there are a bunch of people who
were like oh such collusion like Tony's
just trying to corrupt you this is a
marketing campaign just to get you to
love their video game I streamed it for
like two hours the other day and even in
that stream gave virtually no opinion on
the game if this was some kind of
campaign to make us say nice things
about des training it fails none of the
people who got the cases from what I've
seen aside from Sean or jacksepticeye
have even spoken about debt stranding
and the stuff he said wasn't even that
positive so this answers questions for
both of those people both of those
groups at least not talking about it
because I think it's unethical and no
this wasn't some marketing scheme from
Sony to make me talk about des training
because it has had the opposite effect
in fact Sony actually went the extra
step and I did get a review copy of
deaths training I've been playing the
game for maybe like two weeks before
this deal with the case and all this
stuff came through and got organized
because this is the part that I think
most people don't know
PlayStation could potentially get fined
so did the next part of this video I
have said this in YouTube videos before
when people never really like hearing it
they like to refuse it but I've been in
games media for 10 years so if you're
not gonna trust a first hand sauce I
think you screwing up a bit bad game
reviews are not paid for and if a outlet
was paid to give a positive review
school again doesn't happen if it did
journalists would be tweeting about it
we get off on leaking stuff like that
the company that paid for it would
actually be in extreme financial trouble
more so than the outlet who published
the review and these companies do not
want to take those risks that is what
legal teams are full they have expensive
legal teams who are there to be like
don't do that we will get sued for it do
not do that okay so the other thing I
want to talk about is FTC guidelines
again have kind of already told you that
the publishers would get in trouble
hugely even if an influence that makes a
mistake that they did not let them make
the publisher will still get in trouble
right so if they give a random youtuber
of you code and that random YouTube it
doesn't say this copy was provided by
PlayStation PlayStation gets in trouble
even if they told that person to do that
they could still get in trouble these
guidelines are straight and the latest
FTC guidelines they actually just
updated so you can read all of this on
FTC gov the list of all of these
guidelines that every person who has
ever paid to promote anything will have
to follow you should read over it it's
interesting stuff regardless and part of
this that I always want to mention to
people is if you genuinely believe
something is an FTC concern if you
believe a company was paid for something
to give some opinion to side with
something flag it with the FTC and I
don't want to bore you with the details
myself if you don't care but honestly I
just think these guidelines are really
good we're in an era where Instagram
models of promoting laxatives and saying
that their weight loss pills to young
girls
it's not that they should be arrested
for that it is disgusting what that can
do to people so while in theory the FTC
guidelines maybe some influences would
say it makes that jobs harder or
something
I am aggressively in support almost
think they should be more aggressive and
according to this I technically would be
allowed to say I like or dislike death
stranding that actually does pass the
FTC guidelines basically what I would
have to do is say here's what I think of
the game but for full context they paid
me they gave me this I was provided a
review copy I'd have to like basically
list off all of the things that occurred
so that people can form opinions on
whether they trust what you're saying or
not I think anyway this stuff is a lot
stricter than you would think there's no
way I'm gonna reviewed estimating and
there's no way the PlayStation would
want me to despite people for some
reason thinking that that campaign with
the case was so that I would give the
game a good review even though I didn't
review it anyway this was kind of Randy
I don't know I just think the topics
interesting and encourage people to
learn more about it and totally flag
stuff if you don't
I agree with it I'll believe it Oh think
that it you think it's paid is what I
mean okay friends I'm alone I'll see you
guys next time